- [Narrator] This little
old lady is Button,
a 21-year-old margay.
Her name comes from the
phrase “cute as a button.”
(bright music)
The margay is a tree-dwelling cat
native to the dense forests
in Central and South America.
These expert climbers will hunt, sleep,
and even give birth in the trees.
The margay's wide feet and flexible toes
allow them to climb, jump,
and hang from tree limbs.
Their long heavy tails
keep the animal balanced,
and their large eyes make them
excellent night hunters,
preying on birds, reptiles
and even small primates.
Margays will hardly ever
cross open treeless areas,
making them extremely
sensitive to deforestation.
In addition, the illegal
fur and pet trades
have made this wildcat a
near-threatened species.
The best hope for the
margay's continued survival
is to preserve their
natural forest habitat.
This is the margay.